Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to "The Cat Games".
Now this game...
Is apparently adorable and all about cats!
And I am.. so ready to relax.
Oh dawh.. OH DAWWH!
Oh mah gawdd!
Oh, so good!- oh what is this?
Hello?- oh I don't know why that's happening..
OOH!
IS THIS SUPPOSED TO BE A PASSWORD?
OH! what a great picture!
OAH, ITS AWESOME!
Oh my GOD!
These cats are so talented..
Wheres the porn? Wheres the tab of porn on here?
This doesnt seem right.. These are all actual sports!
Weightlifting?
Badminton!
Volleyball!
Gymnastics
Soccer?
Highjump!
ppfff...Relay!
and Fieldhockey.
*password denied noise* AAAH shit..
I don't know how to do that..
AAH, I'll come back to you!
EUUUGH..
Why- HUH- BAP! BAP! Imma kitty cat.. BAP!
Oohh..!!
You almost BAPP'D it!
Awh, you almost did it- OKAY. So into the cat games we go..
What the hell is this? Why am I looking at the goddamn couch?
*GASPP..*
AWWH, ITS  SOOO CUUuUuuTE!
AAAAGH!
Oh so cute!
OOOH!!
*sparkly noises from the cat-moon*
Whyyy? I don't even know why this exists..  This game is amazing.
In every way, its amazing and I LOVE IT.
Lets do racing!
[Whisper] whuut..?
YAH sure, I wanna know what i'm doing!
IGH dih dieh..
WOOOAH! Move up by- ooh..
*gasp* WOOOOH!
LUK AT ME GOOOO!
OOH its a slippery linoleum!
*tutorial reading*
OOH im so stealthy..
Lookat that underwear!
Look at that wine!
OW!
ooOH it's so CUTE!
AAGH I LOVE THIS GAME!
OH MY GOD!
Oh, "give it a try!" oh it wants me to run in..
Oh boy, alrighty then..
*tutorial reading*
Oh! bluegh, flags 'n' ducks!
Alright okey, alright okay
Alright,  I got you.
*tutorial reading*
OH! So its a risk-reward type of thing..
Take that yeh stoopid dawgs!!
Awh, they look like lil' Chica's!
AOUUUGH!
*giggling* awwwe *more giggling*
Oh, "if you crash into furniture its game over."
EUEEEE-BOINK!
Ah boink-
AAAUGH OW!
My skull...
*tutorial reading*
Okay... alright then.. I'm ready!
Let's do this!
Les' do this!
Hell yeah! oops okay..
I dont know what what I'm trying to do here.
Man, there's a lot more obstacles than I thou-
oOohh okay alright then..
*unsurprised* WAH! I DID TERRIBLY!
Im not a very good cat, but I like that cat-butt painting
that's a good one..
yup, i did shit.
Ok lets try again shall we?
awh, that cute cat in the bottom, oh my God..
Oh, I'm ready!
Okay, this time I'm not gunna suck dong..
That was apparently my first problem..
SCOOTCH!
Awhh, SCOOTCH A DOOCH!
Awh, SCOOTCH KITTY WITTY!
Oh my God, I wonder if I'm able to slide under there oh so perfectly.
Sher-ba-da-boop!
Naw, frick a dick. Ok. HEEAAUH!
Kay gonna go for the flags more than I'm gonna go for that.
HOOBO!
SHOOBEDIBOOP-boop-booboob-bop.
OH MY GOD ITS SO CUTE.
This game is my life now! This game is ever-- awhh..
WELP broke my spine.
Oh my God I did BETTER! YAY, OH MY GOD, LOOK AT THAT LIL CAT IN THE CORNER!
AWH, ITS SO CUTE!
oOH this game is PERFECT!
In every way! Oh I LOVE it! This game was $2!
Im not advertising it or anything, its TWO dollars..
INFINITE enjoyment..
Alright swim challenge.
Oh?
*tutorial reading* "You wanna start on the tutorial?"
YEH Ok.
*tutorial reading*
Yellow toys-? Ohh.
woop.
AUH, SQUEAK-SQWONK!
Yes!!
Click on the pink toys?
ooh! yes! they're hard to get..
Oh, right click!
Ah, I gotta right click on the pink ones.
Yeaaww,, both time at the blue ones!
GODIT
I am so talented...
*tutorial reading*
*inhales in preperation*
AAAAAAAAAHHH!!!
AAAAAAAAAAHHH!!!
AAAAAAAAAAAHHH!!!
AAAAAAAAAAAAHHH!!!
AAAAAAAAAAAAAHHH!!!
Oh, ok...
*click, click...*
*WAP*
Okay!
*GASP*
Ohhhhhhhhh,
I get it!
If it's comin' towards my
HEAD
Then I should probably hit it
Because it's gonna be bad...
So I'm gonna let it hit!
HHHHUUUUUAAAAAAAH!
OH!
OH! (x2)
OW!
OOH!
OH!
Ee
Ah
Ooh, ah!
Gotta regain!
Euuughhh!
*tutorial reading*
*deep voice* Oooh-uh!
Okay,
That sounds-
Nice!
EhDUH
ohh - kay!
I think I got this!
*tutorial reading*
Don't let the bubbles catch you?
BOINK
Ah!
Oh, boy!
OH BOY, OH BOY, OH BOY, OH BOY
AHH, KAY!
Ahright!
Uh, ah!
Ah, Ah!
AH!
AAAAAH!
I'm- I'm getting it!
Ah
Ooh
Ah, Ee
Ah,
OOOH!
LOOK AT ME GO!
Look at me go!
Look at me go.....
Oh, look at me go!
Ooh!
Yes!
Oh, coordination is my name!
Boinkety
boink!
Ah, frick!
Ooh, gotta regain!
Ooh!
Get outta here! *cat hisses as it hits water*
AAAH!
I did pretty good!
I did pretty good, all things considered!
Ohma GAWD!
Ohma God, I love it!
Oh, I love it!
Mm-mm!
A-bap!
A-boop!
A-daboopie!
Boop!
Boop (x2)
And, A-baap!
Oh, and a howbouta
Boop-a-da-bap!!!
Bap fo' yew!
Boinkedy- boink
Boink!
Boink (x2 again)
Vibrato!
Bonk!
Bink!
Bink-bonk!
Shplink Shplonk!
Shplink shplonk...
Blink!
O-ah!
Yeah!
Yeh.
Bl- blonk!
Blink!
Blonk!!!
Blonk
Blink!
Blonk, blink!
Blonk...
Blink!
Blonk!
Blink, blonk!
Blink,
Bloonk!
Blink
blink, blink
Shpoop!
Boi, bai
Blip!
Oh, I'm so good at this!
Omagod, I'm the best cat that ever LIIIVED!
Ah, shit!
Yea!
Who knew I was a cat person, not a dog person?
Someone hafta tell Chica 'bout dat
She's not in the room right now.
Otherwise she'd be DEVASTATED
Emotionally!
Devastated...
♫ Can't get me-e! ♫
♫ I'm too good for yooouuu! ♫
♫ I'm too good for you, ♫
♫ Hoo, hoo, hooo! ♫
Bwap, bep!
Bap, bap!
Oh, GET REKT HIGH SCORE!
Ah, shit!
Ah, ya ya ya ya ya,
YA,YA, YA, YA, YA, YA
Aaand, vibrato!
Augh!
Don bump me!
Hun Bum Me!
Don bum me
Dun bom me!
Waugh
C'mon!
Aah, no!
Ahright, hang on...
Prioritize!
Wuh, wah!
Get back on!
On track...
Shewp!
Ok, ahright...
No! (x12)
Hap!
Woop.
Aaah,
SHIIIT
-TY TITTIES!
TIT-
GAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHH!
Goddammit!
Hey, but I did good!
I got pretty good on the vibrating shower...
I'd say that's a pretty good, gam-dam score!
Oh, hell yeah!
Oh, HELL yeah!
This is a lot less rage in-douche-ing then a lot of the games I've played before!
Rage in-douche-ing!
*The cat goes MWOOW!*
Oh, one last left: "Cat Breed Billiards"
IM REDDY
Show me what-
Oh!
*tutorial reading*
Yah, I'll start it!
Yah, OK, let's do this!
*tutorial reading*
That doesn't seem like the billiards I know!
*MORE tutorial reading*
Turkish Angora
*subtly* I dun no...
Uh!
I don know what deez cat breeds are!
*tutorial reading*
Ok...
Push this white ball
BLUP!
*Cat mrrows*
DIDDIT!
Nah, I didn't do it...
Okay, I got to get the correct ball into a hole!
Which sounds dirty!
And it probably is...
But Imma do my best here.
*Reading text*
*Reading text confused*
Ooh!
*Cat MRROOWRs*
*Reading text*
Watch out for these balls ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
OK!
ALRIGHT!
I got it lil' guy!
I'll do my best here!
I'll make ya proud'a me!
BAHP!
GET
BAP'T!
I guess it- maybe it's like an educational experience, too, because I dunno what the answers are!
NOPE
THAT WAS
NOT IT!
Ok,
So, I knew that one!
The whiter one is a turkish...
But maybe yyyyyyyyy
YEW
FLIP!
Meant to do it!
Meant to do it...
Meant to do that
Okay
Boink!
Nope, I fucked that up!
It- I jus- I just am...
Boink...
GO!
GO, BABY, GO!
Not the white one!
Go, bby, go!
NAICE!
Not correct tho...
nnNOPE!
I am:
♫ DUUUUUUUUUUUUMMB ♫
♫ I COULDN'T'VE GOTTEN WORSE LU- ♫
Aw, FUCK
I D'NO WHAT THEY ARE
Aw, c'mon, man, I dunno!
Cornish red hat-
Rex, rex.
I'm gonna assume it's the one in front.
Wuh!
*cats meow*
Cuz one'a those is not doin' too good!
BAHP!
NOPE!
Not that one!
Okay, c'mon
C'MA!
Cm'a, c'mon
aaaaaaannnd
BAP!
NOT that one!
Okay.
Boink!
Nope, still not!
Wow, y'know my odds are not doin' well for me!
You think I would've gotten this by now,
But the answer is..
Absolutely...
nnnnnnn-
NO-OT!
Ah, frick a dick.
BLAHP!
Nope, not that one.
AAAAAAYYE!
I did okay, I guess!
Man, I was trying to go for that one but it was on the end anyway...
How could I have DONE THAT
The answer is:
I COULDAAAAA-AAUGH-AAAHN!
Havana Brown
Well, this...
Narrows it down
So, It could only be a few...
Of these...
Intimate choices here.
*sniff*
DAMMIT
I'm-a goin for that brown one.
No, I'm goin' for this one brown one first...
BLOINK!
Blaamp, not it?
But I knew that.
Cause it had to be this brown one at da bouttom 'ere
shaaaa
BLINK-BLONK!
Wellp, that didn't work-
O-OKAY
PHYSICS GOT A LITTLE SLOW THERE FOR A SECOND,
IT HAD TO THINK ABOUT IT!
Thought I got that...
YEEAAAAAAYYYYYY!
I did good!
I did reeal good!
Oh, maGod!
OH, HE'S SLEEPING NOW!
OH, YOU'RE SO KYOOT!!!
OH MY GOD!
Oh, my God,
You're so cute,
Okay,
Alright,
Enuffa that...
Enough shouting...
Cats are trying to sleep...
BUTEITHERWAY
That's all the time I have for the Cat Games,
And this is adorable and interesting!
So, If you guys have a solution to this puzzle here:
Lemme know down in the comments below!
I might just solve it on my own time, here
O, wait!
Wait, no, they have letters on their jackets!!!
So, 4 is G
3 is I
7 is O
So, it's E...
Ah, ok, I got this.
E, N
E, N...
E, N, I, G
E, N, I, G, M
♫ E, N, I, G, M, E ♫ x2
♫ E, N, I, G, M, E ♫ x3
♫ E, N, I, G, M, E ♫ x4
♫ E, N, I, G, M- ♫
N, E
♫ E
N
I,G
E ♫
♫ E, N, I, G, N, E ♫
Wait.
E, N, I, G, M!...
N, E...
No,
E, N, I, G, M...
♫ E, N, I, G, M... ♫
E...
O...
W...
E, N, I, G, M...
E
O
W
ENIG-MWOW!
OOHHH!
I GOT AN ACHIEVEMENT!
YAAAAAAAAAAAAYYYY!
I did it!
Okay, I solved it!
It wasn't that hard if you think about it really closely,
But, either way!
That is the Cat Games!
Lemme know what you think of this in the comments below
And I'll provide a link to the game to itself.
In case you wanna indulge in some adorable Cat-ness,
Which I think you do.
So, thank you, everybody, again!
And, as always,
I will seeee you!
In the next video!
BUH- BYEEE!!!!!
♫     ♫     ♫
♫     ♫     ♫     ♫
duh
dun-dah
beh buh
duh duh
BBbboowwww duuuuhhhhhhhhh~